of Ramsey solutions Seth and Lindsay are
with us hey guys how are you hey over
here good to have you so you're here to
do your debt-free scream where are you
from Hershey Pennsylvania fun well
welcome to Nashville it's good to have
you so how much debt have you two paid
off
we paid 54 thousand in 11 months way to
go boom
making what kind of money we were making
95 now we're making 110 excellent cool
great incomes what do y'all do for a
living I'm a special ed teacher mm-hmm
and I'm a Salesforce developer Oh
excellent very cool actually we need one
of those if you want to move to
Nashville we need like six of those
apparently but yeah cool very fun dude
well congratulations you guys what
happened eleven months ago
well we got married okay there's that
yeah so who's that was this both of ours
I had a car loan and we both had a bunch
of student loans okay all right and so
what made you decide that this was one
of the first orders of business of the
new marriage well um after we got
engaged we heard about Financial Peace
University at our local church and we
got involved and we decided that that
was something that we really needed to
do so we cash flowed her wedding I'm
just honored every journey right after
we got home from our honeymoon very cool
did you go you went to the classes as
while you were engaged then yes so part
of your pre marriage counseling so to
speak yes yes choice we made very good
well we're honored Thanks
so you come home and the very first
thing you do is you spend the next year
living on nothing yeah how romantic
for sure I'll bet I'll bet so when did
you guys get out of school um I'm
actually graduating in December oh okay
congratulations I graduated in 2011 okay
all right fun very cool so you you just
you're going to church you're engaged
you see the class you going to class you
go okay we're going to do this and you
get lined up and come back for the
honeymoon go straight into it what was
the hardest part for you guys for this
year
probably not going to restaurants not
stopping shopping habit had a lot of
cheap pizza Friday and date nights yeah
cool very cool
good so did you have a lot of fights
surprisingly no yeah the the first
couple months were the hardest tears the
first couple months during our budget
meetings but then after that just we
just joined together and worked as a
team and it's been it's been smooth
sailing from there no you know what's so
cool is you've set a pattern in your
marriage that if there's a monster that
the two of you can lock arms and kill
the monster
you can gang up on the monsters to the
monster getting between you which
alliance with a lot of marriages and the
monster can be anything it can be
whatever the challenge is that comes at
you but you guys had laid a challenge
right in front of you and you've already
learn the life skill in your
relationship to go kill monsters
together and that you could do anything
now I mean you're incredible this is
you're so set up to win this is awesome
congratulations how does it feel it
hasn't quite sunk in yet yeah we just
paid it off a couple weeks ago so this
is the first month in the first vacation
we have taken since we started this
journey first time you went out to eat
and now we came here so it it definitely
feels different well the good news is
Nashville's got a great restaurant scene
so you'll get some good food while
you're here all right very cool very
cool well congrats you guys
so what do you tell your friends that
are engaged that are you two years ago
what do you tell them a secret to
getting out of that is uh start with a
plan have monthly budget meetings but
everything down on paper so all of your
expenses and give your first ten percent
to God and
um that's good on it
that's good so who's the natural saver
and the natural spender I think he's a
little bit more than I do he what he
saves a little bit more than I do
okay so yeah cuz the pain points for you
were the shopping and they going out to
eat and that was more a personal thing
you were saying there yeah it's not part
yeah it's normal right yeah that's good
that's all I get that's great you you've
conquered the Beast I love you you guys
are incredible very very very well done
that's just excellent and yeah living on
a plan and the communication styles and
everything that you had to work through
the first year of marriage anyway but
this almost gives you a format to do it
doesn't it very well done all right Seth
and Lindsey Hershey Pennsylvania $54,000
paid off in 11 months making 95 now to
110 count it down let's hear a debt free
screen three two one
excellent you two you're rock stars very
very very well done
you